I went to get birth control and I was
there at the counter and went to pay for
it and the the price was very very high
I said wow is this a three six month
prescription no ma'am this is one month
and I said it's cheaper to have a kid
wow and I left it there and now I have
my third son Caden bobert um and so I'm
actually it was it was turned out to be
a really great thing but um I personally
experienced that when times were tough
Lauren bobert has been a staunch
opponent of abortion and Reproductive
Rights she's voted against expanding
access to contraception for millions of
Americans who need it and potentially
are in the position she was once in
we're paying for the birth control is
expensive so she has been someone who if
this story is true
she understands how difficult it can be
and she is voted against making it
easier to access birth control for uh
millions of Americans